how to make a website
if you don't know anything about
websites okay if you're starting a
business
and you don't know about the product
category that you're getting into
you have to find a way to either learn
it yourself or better yet
bring people on board who can help you
okay this comes as a response to
question i got from one of my youtube
viewers jim jones
who wrote in to say i have a question uh
i want to make a micro blogging site my
target market is age 14 and above i'm
currently struggling to find the funding
and right people to help me realize this
dream
as unfortunately i'm not a programmer
what do i do
so jim here's the thing okay if you want
to have a lot of success in this field
it's probably not going to be by you
becoming
a programmer okay that that might help
but if you're not interested in
programming if you're not passionate
about being a programmer
it's not going to work it's going to be
a mediocre product
so you got to think what are you really
good at and then bring people on board
who can support you
the two ways to do it here if you're
building technology product
you need to have somebody on board who
gets technology that's a big thing
that's kind of a big deal right so you
have to find that person
the two ways to do it is one you hire
them and at a startup you don't have a
lot of money to do it
right if you've got tons of backing
that's one thing but you probably don't
have a ton of cash
most of the best startups in the
technology space we're started by people
who get
technology so you need to find the
person who gets technology to guide you
along the way here
the way to do it is find someone who you
can partner up with
find someone who believes the same thing
that you believe in
but doesn't have your skills they have
the technology skills
they want to build the exact same thing
but they have no idea how to
build a company and how to market this
that's where you come in
hopefully i don't know where you come in
you got to tell me what you're good at
hopefully you're good at something that
relates to this and go find that person
how do you find that person you have to
hang around in the circles that relate
to what you're talking about
so here's here's an example let me bring
this home for you in a tangible example
okay
uh i've got a guy who's helping me now
my team named jason
and jason has done a lot of great work
on the branding the design
a lot of the thinking behind the the
business and the website
and taking in the direction that that i
wasn't thinking of before and i didn't
have the skills for
how did i find jason okay
there was an event here in toronto that
i created uh a
coffee shop that i really liked a bus
ran into that coffee shop and the owner
had to close down for a few days can you
imagine a bus
hitting your store like it's hard enough
to be an entrepreneur and here comes
this bus that plows through your front
door so they had to shut down while they
built the front of their store back up
and when they opened up again
i put out a note to my newsletter list
to say
hey guys here's what happened to the
store little nicki's
i want to go surprise them one day and
just
buy their stuff grab some coffee meet
you entrepreneurs and talk business and
support this entrepreneur
why did i do this because i believe in
entrepreneurs that's what i do i love
entrepreneurs
everything i do is about
entrepreneurship and the people on my
team have to love entrepreneurs too
so when i went to that event i met jason
there
it's the first time i met him in person
and we we hit it off and nothing
happened right away we didn't have an
idea to work together on something right
away but over time things developed and
we hit it off
and it worked well because we believed
in the same thing
but we had different skill sets and we
found
each other by going to events that
related to what we believed in
so this thing that you're trying to
build who's it going to help
how is it going to help them why is this
important like this has to mean
something to you
and start going to events or create your
own event
that relate to that topic if it was
around entrepreneurship for me i would
create an entrepreneurship event i would
go
to any entrepreneur event here in my
city or conference that i wanted to
learn about
i would go there because the people
there they like the same thing
they believe the same thing that i do
but they have different skills
and that means partnership opportunities
okay you got to find that person if you
want to build a successful
technology-based company
you need somebody who gets technology
you're not going to get funding without
that person you said you're trying to
get funded you go to banks you go to
investors you go to angels vcs whoever
it is
nobody's going to give you money if
you're a technology company
without the technology person so you
either have to find that person
or take your company in a different
direction that doesn't rely on
technology
where you can use your strengths and you
don't need the partners
those are your options great question
believe
those are watching like the video give
it a thumbs up below make sure to do
more
and let me know what you think leave a
comment below you have a question put it
below make a video response
thank you so much and i'll see you soon